Cornell West is running for president uh
Under The People's Party
umbrella which does not currently have
ballot access in even a single state
also it has been accused of playing a
little koi with the pro-putin stuff
how much do you think I should talk
about Cornell West's candidacy given
these realities he made the big
announcement on Russell Brand's show not
exactly a beacon of progressivism and
I'm getting I hate to say it folks
I'm getting Tulsi gabbard Vibes where
there is a small subsection of the left
that falls for it
and then you go wait a second like
what's actually Progressive at this
point or is it just contrarian
reactionary Russell Brand People's Party
no ballot access already saying to
others if you don't talk about it you're
not really a progressive